welcome to this video let's see IVA Lou
I've voulu from the US are playing
something else so go for Dutch set up
Lenny great yeah before this is some an
interesting line line that I have played
myself a number of times trying to play
with Bishop e6 and Bishop g8 mrs. line I
have recently seen and it's interesting
black tries to play against this
slightly weakened c4 pond and spraying
very quickly
hope you're not quite sure about rock t
1 what is the idea I cannot play you for
at the moment this is the idea taking
twice taking see form yeah well should I
play a 5mm takes texts yeah I probably
should it's a bit difficult to get to
get any counter play if I don't play it
now okay if you place if interesting
night c4 but I can't play a 43 right
away and I will do that all this looks
quite nice for for black yeah that's
very nice even takes Queen takes Knight
g4s is almost winning on the spot and if
he takes I'll take f2 on IG for both
very good yeah this worked really this
worked to perfection for black let's see
let's be precise come take yeah he needs
to play king h1 i think if i take check
if it if you recaptures i take c for now
this is this is this is immediately
winning check can you have 193 kingi 123
walking you 193 walking everything yeah
I needed to play King edge 1 which is a
really ugly but it was the movie near to
play ok
the question is white resigns after
Queen ecigs a guy can also just take the
rook night g2 king of 2a serve the night
doesn't have a square to retreat oh yeah
surprisingly quick win from this opening
yeah I think it came to this position
here you should play you form a
must-play form and then we have
typically complicated position from the
Dutch I am probably player for jam then
maybe c5 very complicated stuff he's got
nine c-46 strategically speaking black
always looks a bit a bit term
questionable here the computer is giving
wider substantial advantage more than
one pawn I'm surprised that its own so
I'm so bad but maybe I may be the
successor is a big square and the sir no
doubt about that but the computer now
gives the light eft XG 38 x g3 and then
Nigel which really looks entirely
harmless I thought may h h 6 g5 of
course you need to probably just toss
the beep on after night d6 later yeah
probably probably why this pattern I
don't really know this opening too well
the Duchess are very complicated and can
easily lead to trouble if you don't know
what you're doing what I know is that
this is downright don't write the
problematic here here yeah this is
probably losing almost check yeah King
edge bonus what he needs to do
of course after NAT G for its it's no
fun but it's slightly tougher than this
which instantly loses material alright
thanks for watching